okay good to go later
thank you okay good evening everybody
and welcome
to tonight's meeting of the executive
um the meeting obviously is
um being webcast so if you want to come
in to speak very
hand function at the bottom of the
participant list
item one is attendances i'm not aware of
um any apologies um
item two is questions from members of
the public none have been
received item three is declarations of
interest are there any declarations of
interest any of the items on the agenda
no okay item four is minutes
so we are receiving the minutes of the
meetings
held on the 2nd and 23rd of november and
also the 14th of december can they be
agreed please
thank you item five is masters from
council or overview and scrutiny
committees
and there is the um scrutiny review of
the draft budget proposals councillor
action did you want to come in on this
at all yes
thank you leader um how do you know uh
two scrutiny
budget sessions were held in december
and you will see scrutiny members have
endorsed a budget scrutiny report
which is before you uh tonight
the main areas of discussion from the
sessions
are captured within the body of the
report alongside
a series of recommendations
scrutiny members covered a great deal of
budget issues and i'll just
you know identify some of those
they include the budget gap the loss of
council income the use of
council reserves to support the
council's
services the extra council costs
of the pandemic the council's
investment strategy and you know quite a
bit more
and i think you know the loss of the
income
is a is a big uh issue um
because of the pandemic and and i think
all of these issues
are a challenge for the executive
and will need extensive monitoring
and scrutinizing throughout the year and
the scrutiny members i have to tell you
are very happy to help and support
the executive uh within that challenge
and clearly like i think every other
council
uh in in the uk uh the pandemic
has meant that this last year has been
like
no other year in the history of
trafford you know i've been around a
long time but i've never known anything
like this
and scrutiny members um recognize the
pandemic has had a huge
impact on our residents and businesses
in trafford
and i think the rightly the
concentration of the council
has been focused on the well-being of
our
residents and communities and businesses
to ensure that they have stayed
as safe as possible and as financially
stable as possible throughout these
extreme times
and without doubt this period has been a
massive strain
and challenge for the council's budget
situation
and we've tried to capture that within
within the report
and finally an important consideration
will be
uh as we get the uh you know the
population
vaccinated and if we come out of the
pandemic
will be how we deal with the recovery
plan
and again you know scrutiny would
welcome involvement in
developing and delivering of the
recovering plans
because it will be a very you know
difficult time
for us to actually get trafford moving
in the way that we all
want it to and lastly i'd just like to
thank the executive members
and the corporate leadership team for
their help and
a particular thanks obviously uh to to
the executive member and
um and the finance director
uh in the help and the support and the
contribution they've given to this
scrutiny
process and finally the members of the
scrutiny who work so hard
with regard to this and you know that
input has been
invaluable so thank you leader
thank you councillor acton and echo
those thanks and also
my thanks to you as chair of the
committee for leading that process it's
always
a really important piece of work
especially given the challenges that we
um uniquely face this year so so thank
you very much
um okay we'll move into um the
excuse me leader oh yes sorry for
interrupting i don't seem to have a
raised hand function
just obviously there are a number of
recommendations that were made in the
scrutiny uh report and presumably
the executive is going to consider those
and respond back to the
recruiting committee in relation to
those recommendations in due course
is that right yes that is right thank
you um
jane is slightly premature there and
since um
then councillor but's hand has
a question on this uh it's just that the
i mean given the
this is on regarding the adult services
in the council of uh acquisition of two
care homes
uh which is within the item isn't it
confirmed
yeah uh i mean given this
to advise counselor but this isn't a
debate on the budget this is a scrutiny
report to the executive of the deep dive
that they have done so
it's not to um discuss individual budget
lines
no but it's just a question around the
the the script
with the scrutiny of it yeah sure thank
you uh
now i was just trying to say that you
know i mean we realized that in the
staffing costs and compliance costs
associated with running the care homes
and
in fact the previous administration
struggled to try and keep
care homes viable in fact and indeed
hemorrhaged taxpayers money
leaving other services you know reduced
with budgets
and with with the council taxpayer
having to pick up a fair bit of the
custom which ended up with that adult
social care precept
so i mean it just seems it would take
some then
some special kind of accounting to
forecast
a saving however small that she makes a
reference to cancel
that question but i thought you
misunderstood what i said to you before
because you've begun to undertake
scrutiny of budget proposals there
rather than to raise a question as to
the scrutiny
committee's work on budget so that is
certainly out of scope for this meeting
but i'm sure if you've got those
concerns when we have the budget
executive next month
and indeed budget council you'll be
aware from your many years of service
that that's the appropriate time to
raise those so we'll we will move into
um the next item on the agenda which
is the um leisure strategy review now
obviously this is a significant item but
i would remind members that there is
a part two report to follow and to
censor any questions that they've got
for this section
of the meeting on the items that are um
outlined
in the paper at item six rather than
the part two paper and obviously if we
do maps at any point into um discussing
anything that's more appropriate for
part two i'm sure that the monitoring
officer will
jump in and advise me that we need to um
move into the closed section of the
meeting or rule that question out until
we get to
that point there are clearly commercial
considerations for us there so
if i could ask councillor patel to move
part one of the leisure strategy review
plea thank you leader
our leisure centres provide a universal
resource to our residents
from school swimming lessons to
gymnastic programmes
they provide a chance for all ages to
access a gym and to join a wide range of
exercise classes
residents have grown up with our centers
and many are loyal members and
pay-as-you-go customers of trafford
leisure
covid has highlighted health
inequalities in trafford and as we
emerge from the pandemic
improving physical health and well-being
is critical to protecting residents in
the longer term
too many of our residents are not
engaged in regular physical activity
our leisure stock is outdated and in
need of investment to enable them to
retain customers and to appeal to a
wider audience
a key requirement of any investment into
our leisure provision in trafford
is that it must be delivered at a cost
neutral position
the cost of prudential borrowing must be
able to be paid back through revenue
raised by our leisure centres
the impact of covid on leisure operators
has been huge
largely closed since march 2020 when
they were able to open they operated
under capacity to meet covered safe
standards
an already challenged service is like
the local authority itself
facing a huge financial challenge moving
forward
in july 2020 a report to execs set out
the very real financial challenge faced
by trafford leisure
and the subsequent loans and grants
provided by traffic council
it was also reported in september 2020
that the council will be undertaking a
full review of our leisure strategy
and i'm reporting back today on the
first stages of this
max associates were commissioned to
undertake this review
they were tasked with considering how
our leisure center services are managed
they have been asked to develop a
sustainable investment proposal
to improve the leisure stock and to link
this management of an investment into
our fiscal
assets with a wider with our wider
strategic objectives and outcomes for
health
and well-being in the borough turning to
the report i will
briefly summarize sections two and three
which should be ready in conjunction
with the appendices which provide
detailed localized data on our leisure
market and population needs
using a framework developed by sport
england to support local authorities to
make
strategic and meaningful decisions about
investment into leisure provision
max associates have produced a strategic
outcome planning model
referred to throughout this report as
sophum
the supplement recognises that sport and
leisure is not simply for sports sake
but that strategically directed services
and facilities
can have a significant impact on
physical and mental health
economic regeneration educational
attainment the environment and social
cohesion
stage one of the sophum looked at
outcomes max associates reviewed
national regional local strategies
consulting with our public health team
clinical commissioning group traffic
leisure and stakeholders involved
in our local delivery pilot in
partington we have identified what we
want to achieve through investment and
development of our leisure centres
that is outcomes connected to our
corporate objectives
in health and well-being successful and
thriving places
children and young people and green and
connected
stage two of the sophomore provides an
insight into the leisure market in
trafford
it provides a clearer picture and
understanding of our borough's leisure
needs
enabling better place-based
decision-making
this stage considered barriers to
participating in activity
opportunities to change behavior and
highlights where future interventions
will make the biggest sustainable
difference
critically this now links our
legislative strategy
to our physical activity strategy which
is currently being refreshed
and the development of the active travel
plan
section 5 turns to our leisure centres
back in october 2018 executive approved
proposals for new build leisure centres
in stretford and ultranam
this approach required a significant
captain investment from the council
and includes associated financial risks
notably around the financing of the
prudential borrowing required to
undertake the projects
alongside this these new build proposals
required securing of capital receipts
and the acquisition of land or
partnerships with third parties
which today have proved unachievable
further to these risks we have seen the
leisure market turned on its head by
covid
and whilst we are currently bidding
financial funds for our leisure services
and have diverted leisure reserves to
support trafford leisure
we face an uncertain leisure market as
we emerge from restrictions
since 2018 we have seen the successful
transformation of ernst and leisure
centre to move earnston
praised by the leisure industry and
extremely well received by customers
it has attracted significant numbers of
new members
whilst it has not been able to operate
fully during the pandemic
it is seen as a model for future
investment
in light of this financial uncertainty
for trafford leisure and the council
the previous rebuild options are no
longer considered financially viable
it is therefore proposed that we move to
options for the refurbishment of
ultraman stratford
alongside the addition of sale leisure
centre with the aim being to replicate
the success of move homestead
i recognise that the last time residents
in alternate were consulted on their
leisure centers was around a new build
i know too that the public have followed
the council's attempts to acquire the
former b q
site to develop a new centre in
stratford i would like to take this
opportunity to reassure residents that
on the basis of what has been achieved
at move ernst
a refurbishment option will see their
centers transformed into modern
fit-for-purpose facilities this isn't a
lick of paint
it's a significant remodeling and
upgrading of our centres providing new
spaces and facilities
i would like to extend an invitation on
behalf of trafford leisure to members
when it's safe to do so to come and
visit move armstrong to see the
facilities for themselves
understanding there are concerns from
residents around this new approach i've
taken time to go back over the summary
of consultation with altringham
residents
i can see that among the top of wish
lists for improved facilities there is a
desire for a new gym a fitness suite
fitness classes in a cafe with the main
barrier to using the center the
condition of the facilities themselves
these ambitions will be met with the
move armstrong style refurbishment
critically this refurbishment approach
will allow for plans to be developed for
sale leisure centre
which is a popular centre that serves a
large catchment
alongside this refurbishment our centers
require more immediate investment into
essential condition works existing
approved capital program and funding
earmarked in the draft capital programme
for 2122
will support these short-term condition
works
and which will allow and our leisure
centers to remain
open and continue operating when they're
able to do so
this funding will also be used to
undertake design works to ultrasound
stratford and sale
there will be further detail on the
funding and programming works in the
february budget paper
in conclusion what residents want is a
leisure service that can offer modern
accessible appealing facilities
what the council needs to achieve this
is a financially sustainable investment
plan
whilst we are facing huge challenges i
believe this report sets out the
building block for realistic
for a realistic plan to invest in and
improve our leisure centres
finally i would like to offer a
heartfelt thank you to the offices at
traffic council
and trafford leisure our partners and
max associates
for their support and hard work on this
extensive piece of work
which was undertaken during a very
challenging time
thank you leader thank you
councillor patel um are there any
questions or comments from members of
the executive cognizant of the scope of
part one
papers
no okay there are a couple of hands up i
will come first to counsel alam
please uh thank you very much uh leader
the report before us tonight does refer
as councilor patel has already indicated
to the report
of october 2018 where we
first saw that rebuild cost of
uh circa 46 million
now the reported executive in october
2018 also quoted a song
of uh circa 20 million just to
maintain stratford and altering them
at a i'd a quote basic level of health
and safety
close quote and that such expenditure
would have no visible impact
from the customer's perspective and
therefore guarantee
no additional uh income now in the case
of altering them in the 2018 report
it stated that this center quote is at
the end of its economic life
and refurbishment is not an option close
quote
so presumably we would need to spend the
sum considerably greater than 20 million
if the centers that strep for the
northern gun are to attract customers
and revenue uh for them to survive and
certainly in the case of altering them
uh it would appear that the
refurbishment costs would be quite
uh considerable so is this not a case
of trying to make a silk purse out of a
sales here and that's
probably my you know the first point i
want to make
my second one leader will potentially
stray into
part two but i think i can safely sort
of just ask
at this stage whether we as a council
have some good
estimates of the refurbishment uh costs
because without those of course it would
seem uh
sort of strange to be making the kind of
decision that you're being expected to
make this evening although i do
acknowledge that there are
further phases of the uh the sophum
work uh to be done so acknowledging that
that last
uh question uh uh council patel may want
to leave over
uh until we get to part two thank you
leader
thanks councillor patel what i would say
i mean you're right to raise the um
the costs around condition works they
are significant
our leisure centers have not been
invested in for
many many years that can has been kicked
down the road
presumably under previous
administrations too
and you know we're facing the impact of
that
now um there is continuation the
supplement isn't finished so
a big part of what max associates are
currently working on
is um those the costs of those condition
works
and the programming around any sort of
redesign and refurbishment works
you're right the condition works might
not have a visual impact
but what there's an an effort to try and
coordinate the condition works with the
refurbishment work so that there's no
um there's an overlap and best value is
made so
a new boiler is a new boiler if that
makes sense
um but for more detailed costs
i think we're going to have to wait
slightly further down the line
um and perhaps cover that under part two
as well
andrew okay thanks councillor patel um
councillor welton
uh thank you leader um
very much following up uh councillor
lam's point you know
obviously people in austria will be very
disappointed to you know that this is
going to once again take a lot longer
it's nearly nearly ten years since we've
been promised a new leisure center in
ultraman and it does seem like this will
be more expensive in the long run than
than a new build you know that was the
reason for the um
you know for for the latest the most
recent suggestion which was a new build
on the altair
site i think people will be wanting to
know you know
we really want people to want the
council to be upfront about whether the
leisure center
is going to be closed this time because
the previously we were told that
you know when when the refurbishment or
rebuild was going to be on the same site
we were told that
that somehow magically would keep the
center open you know
i think people would really like to like
a straight answer as to whether the um
whether the leisure center is that what
the leisure centers are going to be
closed and for how long
and what is going to be the um you know
the how are the
services going to be provided if
possible um
by other means um also i'm looking at
the wider um sophum which is an
absolutely awful name
for a report it's uh it's very strong on
getting people
to um to move more creative active space
but these recommendations are very
actively
of you know very narrowly about leisure
center provision and i want to know when
we can expect to hear more
about creating wider active space
particularly in the altrum area for
wheeled sports such as skateboarding
scooting and bmx if you look at tables
fixed of page 95
of the report uh you know demonstrates
that you know that there's
virtually a complete lack of facilities
for these sports
in the south of the south of the borough
particularly around the altringham area
um you know and i'd urge you to consider
the use of the space to incorporate
these sports
or to look at the use of um altrium golf
course which
which a lot of people have discovered
during this you know this period but has
had a similar lack of investment over
time and is this
you know there is alongside the gulf
which of course we want to continue has
you know prevent
presents options on there for you better
use of land
um for provision of um sports that you
know that the kids can get involved with
that they're actually interested in
um and they can get there easily you
know rather than having to cross the
across the borough or the other side of
the m60 to access this provision
thank you very much
thank you um the costs of the
refurbishment
and so replied to council lamb are being
worked through
with max associates and we will be in a
position to
explain that more fully um when that
work is completed
in terms of um keeping the center open a
key part of
the move armstrong refurbishment was
that the center
was you know kept open during the
refurbishment works
as far as possible and that maintained
that income
into move armstrong um i'm not in a
position currently
to say to say what will happen at
ultranam but it would be the ambition of
us
of us all and traffic leisure to
maintain services from mulching and
whilst refurbishment was ongoing
but clearly we need to to work through
the the practicals of that
um your point about the
wider outcomes and active and active
travel and opportunities to use
land and facilities for a sort of a a
wider agenda i will raise i will
cover in part two but it's a real
ambition of mine
and trafford council to not just fixate
on our
leisure centers but to look at them as
part of the community as a hub
in the community and to look at the land
around it and and see how we engage
um people in less formal um
settings than a leisure center and
alternate golf course
clearly comes under that one of the last
board meetings i had with trafford
leisure in february before
in person before the pandemic we
discussed
um potential opportunities at ultringham
golf course
for opening up um uh opportunities for
young people to come and try out gold
for opening up walking and cycling
and scooting routes around the park
obviously that
has been um delayed by uh covid but yes
more people than ever have seen
and and experienced the these green
spaces and it's really important that we
continue to keep them as accessible as
possible i absolutely agree with your
point there council welcome
thanks because i'm not seeing anybody
else
um wanting to come in on this so um
as i say we'll return to this item in
part two but there are seven
recommendations as per
pages one and two of the report can they
be agreed please really
all right thank you okay item seven is
the education in early years basic need
and send capital
um report so um i'll come to councillor
heinz firstly
um and then if counselor carter wants to
add anything of course
um we'll come to her too thanks
leader um so i think the report this
evening
is fairly self-explanatory so i'll just
talk through the key
aspects of it um in relation to
education capital funding and the
council has a statutory duty to provide
sufficient places in schools and early
year settings
and to meet the needs of children and
young people with send
and to support this the council received
a basic needs capital funding
and for expansion of pupil places of
18.1 million for
1920 and 7.84 million
for 21.22 um and
send capital allocation of 1.75 million
um for 1819 to
2021 um primary school admissions have
seen
an over subscription um which is most
prominent
in sale um 11 applicants in the first
catchment area who
had applied on time couldn't be
allocated a place at any of their
preferred schools
or any other school within a reasonable
distance because they were all over
subscribed
um trafford then negotiated 10
additional reception places at the first
as an emergency measure
and that was through funding an
additional teacher and accommodating
and the class within the existing open
plan reception area
but clearly a more permanent
accommodation will be required
um as the children move up through the
school
um these places were actually in
addition
to an early utilization of 15
reception places at worthington um which
was a planned expansion that was
actually planned in for september 21
and all 15 of these places were
allocated
and in upper-year groups um
over-subscription
is also an issue um in sale east and
west um and um
there are 35 additional places which
have been
accessed in early in year five
at 20 at brooklyn's primary school and
15
at worthington primary school and
so the proposal is to expand
um the furs from um two to three
forms of entry providing 30 additional
places
in sale west um in each year group
this will consolidate the 10 emergency
places
already allocated and will also meet
demand from the planned developments
provide
170 to 267 additional
affordable housing units within the firs
catchment area
um in with secondary admissions um
over subscription um in sale west
continues
in the secondary uh sector um
every year a number of vulnerable
children are affected by
um the primary over subscription um
and they then cannot um achieve a place
at the nearest secondary school and so
officers are at the very initial stages
of exploring options to address this um
but future proposals will be funded from
an unallocated 5.4 million pounds
um in terms of send capital completed
schemes include
edgerton um and mana academy
expansions and there's hoists at pixar
academy
a training kitchen and music studio
development at gorsh hill studios
and there's ongoing discussions um with
regards as
a small specialist class provision
um building works on site at delamed to
build the new hydrotherapy pool
um are ongoing but there are some
increased
costs due to additional um foundation
work
and that's now required and so the
proposal here
is to reallocate 340 000 pounds
um for the completion and that was
allocated to the the completion of
edgerton um
and that will now be reallocated into
the send
capital pot so um the additional
um costs of delaminate hydrotherapy pool
um can be accommodated within that
um the report also gives an update with
regards
and stanford park um there's on work
uh ongoing work exploring the
feasibility
of um building expansion um which
uh is is there are some challenges in
this area
um and the buildings have been um grade
two
listed on that site and there is a
separate report
um which is due to come to executive um
next month um or in the very near future
um which will cover um consultation
on um separate proposals to amalgamate
the two schools
um but that's not actually within scope
of this report
um in terms of early years trafford has
a buoyant child care market
and despite the challenges of copic 19
it is still anticipated
and that in the majority of localities
the sector will be able to meet
demand but obviously it is appreciated
that that particular
um sector is facing considerable
challenges
um and so a more in-depth sufficiency
and sustainability monitoring exercise
um
is taking place to look at the impact of
covid
um so the report is seeking approval for
the schemes um and the recommendations
are on page one so i'm happy to take
questions but
um as council western said we also have
uh councillor carter and i think karen
samples as well
um who might be able to help as well if
there are some more technical
um questions thank you leader thanks
councillor heinz councillor carter i
don't think you wanted to add anything
[Music]
just from the last council meeting that
we had before just in
before christmas in december um
councillor chilton asked a question
about the furs
and on the back of that myself and karen
samples actually went into the school a
couple of weeks ago
and we had a meeting with the head and
with can
i say now everybody is um happy with the
proposals for us to go ahead with the
expansion
and um you know it's a little bit of a
learning curve for us as well
so i'm i'd like to thank him for
bringing that to our attention
[Music]
thank you for that any questions or
comments from members of the executive
no counselor answer me
you very much um just three points uh
really so while i'm clearly familiar
with this
report my first question though is
around timing um
i'm not entirely sure or it's not
entirely clear whether the report is
retrospectively seeking permission for
this year's capital programme
clearly which we're nearly at the end of
or whether it's a forward-looking view
for 2021 onwards but the previous report
was in june 19 so i'm not sure whether
we would have expected a report in june
20
and then therefore another report in
june 21 so i'm not to
to what extent that this scheme's like
it's not it's not entirely clear to me
what
so that's my first question the second
one um the group has previously raised
both scrutiny at planning and at full
council
um an apparent disconnect between uh the
sort of planning permission
consents that are being granted and then
people place provision
that sits alongside it and i wonder
whether it would be appropriate in
future for
councillor heinz councillor right to
perhaps bring a more forward-looking
view
about the years ahead especially in sale
and because we know there's significant
pressure
on primary places and to try and give
members confidence that there is
a link between those two two parts of
the council
and then thirdly um given that the
2020 admission round led to some of
these emergency measures being made at
affairs and elsewhere in worthington
um what what's the council's view on
this year's admissions round and then
the likely
reaction that's needed for people place
planning for this
forthcoming 2021 academic year thank you
very much
thank you council ramsey councillor
wines did you want to come back on that
yeah thanks um councillor answers so i
think we
we have um the send capital report comes
um every year where we have the forward
look so i think what this report does
um is it acknowledges the works um that
have already taken place over this year
so it's kind of a recap over
um those things that have happened um
but should have been
agreed a previous execs and and were
agreed at previous executives
um and then agrees
the schemes for for next year
um and that i think covers the the
timing
and in terms of the planning and i do
think you make a really good point
actually and it's something that
um we are working a lot more closely now
there is a
a working group to do exactly that in a
way that i don't think has happened
in the past and and i think that is a
really important um aspect really so
that we can
um make sure that those two things um
are
are absolutely married up and and in
terms of the
2020 admissions and full block
um i think is is karen on
um the call just to come in on on that
at all
yeah i am i'm here councillor hines
um yeah we we're not at the point yet
um councillor anstey is to the
definitive picture
in terms of the admissions round that's
been worked through through the
admissions team currently
so at the minute we're looking at
reception place allocations and then
after that it'll be the secondary school
allocations as well
um but i think we completely agree that
actually
um we we very often get an influx
of children and young people into the
authority
and where we do have to make and quite
sudden decisions as to how we
how we find a a place for these children
and young people
we have recognized that there has been
um a number of uh children and young
people that have come from overseas
and at the moment we're we're managing
um
securing places for those young people
into school
we have got a challenge of covid as well
um
and trying to work with schools whilst
obviously we've got reduced attendance
anyway because of the covered
restrictions
in determining a place for them it has
made it a lot more complex
um but completely take your point cancer
and steam
and uh you know it's certainly something
that we can continue to report on going
forward
in terms of place planning and managing
some of the the pressures and the
demands that we have
we do have a paper that's going to
children and young people scrutiny
around place planning
so there's probably likely to be more
detail contained within that report
thanks um okay i've got councillor
coggins
thanks very brief a procedural point and
just i've noticed that some of these
reports have the
new information at the front about the
climate
impacts this one doesn't and we did
agree in september that all future
reports would have it
um and it is an idea that we have been
asking for for about a year and a half
and this one doesn't have i think um
the um the boundary commission one has
carbon reduction
and um and i think it's the equality one
has
one of the others has climate
implications or something along those
lines
so just um appealing that we could make
sure there's some uniformity in there
um and remember the point of that was
that when the exec are making these
decisions they can actually look at
these and they make these decisions
knowing what the the climate
implications are and so i suppose
it'd be great if everyone was was
looking at those and noticed any any
uncertainties
thank you yeah we'll take an action to
make sure that there is a standard
template
that that document does exist so um i'm
not quite sure what's happened here but
um
certainly moving forward will ensure
that all of the teams have got the
the correct template thank you
councillor copkins councillor holden
please
that's better i might should cut you all
off thank you leader
my questions about the consultation
on this process around furs
which i'm sure you will uh the people
involved will appreciate
is fairly and squarely in the middle of
some areas
i understand consultation has gone on
with
school and with the
governors of the school how much
consultation
has taken place with residents
and particularly potential parents
sending their children to first school
because there's some
assumptions made in this report about
travel
and distance to furs which i don't think
work with primary school children
where some considerable distances are
being assumed
that uh will allow people from templey
or simply west to be allocated places
at this school thus adding to the
already
rather difficult traffic situation
so summing up what consultation with
residents
and with parents do you intend to do
thank you
thanks um council behind or councillor
carter
um council carter do you want to come in
there or
or perhaps and i was gonna pass that
over to karen actually
if i'm honest john i don't think we have
done consultation with residents
and i'm not sure that's something that
we would do as as a matter of course
when we're expanding
um you know just adding another year
group into a school
but i'll i'm looking at karen to double
check that
i mean certainly at the moment obviously
councillor holden we've
approached the school about the
potential viability of the
the project um clearly from a
feasibility study point of view
we've looked at um where there is scope
to expand a school
within that area and the furs is one
which does have that that potential it
has
it has the land to be able to do it and
whereas a lot of our schools now
we are finding are are in real pressure
um
and there is there's very little room in
terms of meeting demands for additional
places now
and furs already has some um existing
buildings that
uh are on site some mobile classrooms if
you like
um so again we we recognize that there
was the potential
um as a as a feasibility uh
exercise to expand there
clearly as we move through the project
and we determine
um you know what that's going to mean as
well as in terms of what the building is
going to look like
et cetera et cetera and that can be
something that will take away to ensure
we involve and link in with the school
through parent governors uh and
therefore then the community as well
thanks karen and councillor evans
thank you chair um and thank you thank
you for the report and
it's clear there were some considerable
challenges in 2020 which
uh obviously the officers managed to
meet and possibly we might have the
similar
challenges in 2021 and i suspect we'll
meet those challenges
but we've got massive uh ambitions for
building
it will be good uh really just picking
up in the back end of council of
ancients
bit it would be good to have a matching
plan to school places given that many
communities are choosing traffic
specifically for the school provision
and and we may be failing them have we
any idea what some length of time
council hands that might take to put
together an ambitious plan rather than a
reactive plan
yeah and i think this needs
so we do need to be a little careful but
councillor hines did you want to come in
on that
sorry lady yes um yeah i mean yes there
will be some element of
reactivity but i think um as i was
saying before that there is now
um a a working group um to do
exactly that actually to bring forward
um
plans because you're absolutely right
there is an ambitious
and quite rightly so programmed for um
you know for for house building
and and as part of that we want to make
sure that
um sufficiency for education places um
forms part of that so um so all of that
is
is is being looked at at the moment so
thank you for that
thank you i'm not seeing anybody else
who wants to
um come in on this um so the
recommendations are us
per the report can they be agreed please
thank you okay um item
eight is the corporate equality strategy
for
2021-25 councillors later please
thank you leader i'm really pleased to
bring our equality strategy
to this evening's exec it seems that
there has been there hasn't been one for
some
time so it's positive that this has now
been prioritized
i would like to thank all the officers
and staff for the huge amount of work
that they have already gone
that has already gone into developing
our strategy for trafford council
and for trafford ccg the policy should
be read in conjunction
with the uh poverty strategy and will be
in place until 2025.
however this doesn't mean that we were
putting it to one side and bringing it
out again in 2025
this is a living document and we will
continue continuously improve and
develop our services to staff
and residents along the way this
strategy will underpin
all the work of trafford council and
trafford ccg
as we want to be an exemplar we want to
be exemplar employers
and a borough of best practice so there
will be regular updates via exec
over the life of this strategy our main
objectives are to eliminate
discrimination
in all its forms in life in line with
the equality act of 2020
to advance equality for all persons
covered by protected characteristics
making sure we don't leave any residents
behind in trafford
you will see from the strategy that
addresses our public
and public our public equality duty it
sets out our
equal equality objectives it covers our
population
it covers our leadership and roles
and our roles as employers it covers how
we will commission
and provide services to our residents
it also looks at how we will regulate
our environmental stand
and our regulatory and environmental
standards
it will look at how we will engage with
our communities and achieve a community
cohesion
it will also look at our responses to
covid19
and how it has exposed inequality across
our borough
and across the country and the
improvements we will see
will impact positively on our health and
wellbeing
on the health and well-being of our
residents
and also it looks at our responses to
george floyd
and black lives matter
we have unfortunately seen over several
years now
some who feel empowered to speak out
against people with protected
characteristics
and abuse and assault and not include
them when making decisions that clearly
is not a trafford value
trafford is a diverse borough and this
needs to be reflected
in what we deliver as a council a ccg
and also how we engage with providers
and stakeholders for our residents
i feel that we are starting on a good
footing but there is room for
improvement
we are currently producing a more
user-friendly document to sit alongside
this one on our website we will engage
with staff groups
trade unions residents stakeholders
partners to help us sense check so that
we become more inclusive
the strategy feels like a good starting
point it feels very inclusive
but the delivery of it will tell us if
we are a success
we won't shy away from difficult
conversations or situations
we will use the strategy to do the right
thing for trafford
and i hope the exec can approve the
strategy this evening thank you leader
thank you councillor slater are any
questions or comments from members of
the executive
councillor freeman please
thank you leader i just want to support
everything that council slater
has had to say i think this is a
fantastic piece of work
and it's the first time we've built an
up-to-date strategy since
the early 2000s which i think speaks
volumes for
what went on previously so i think it's
do i commend this to to the executive
thank you thank you councillor patel was
that an indication
just briefly leader just to say i really
welcome this report
um as councillor say slater said we've
got
quite an increasingly polarized public
debate and we seem to have taken some
backwards steps
into in terms of equalities so it's an
important
push back against you know hatred and
intolerance so
yeah welcome this report thank you
thank you councillor whittem
yeah likewise leader just wanted to
welcome this report and thank
councillor slater and all the officers
for for the work on this
and as councillor slater also said it
should be ready in conjunction with
the poverty strategy and i think it's a
really important
moment really for us as trafford council
to be
taking forward the poverty strategy
bringing in an equality strategy it's it
kind of
i think sets out our stall as an
administration for for the sort of
impact we want to have
um in the borough um on these very very
important
um issues and also really timeless as
councillor patel said given the kind of
recent rise in
in hate crime and discrimination that
we've seen um across the country in
in recent years it's really really
important that we set out our stall
on this issue and and do what we can to
to combat
um the challenges that we face
thank you um questions or comments more
broadly um i've got councillor cobbins
thank you just briefly to echo all the
welcoming we've had already on behalf of
the green group um it's it's really
important that the
the council um stand up as the others to
point out in these very um polarized and
divided times for these issues so thank
you
thank you and council miss blackburn uh
thank you leader
um i concur with what councillor slater
said it's
necessary documents it's detailed
documents
and it's a living document and thank you
for all the hard work
and can i make four points
thank you um 0.3.1 with regard to
mandatory training and equalities as a
leader
can i ask who will be trained uh how it
will
it'll be delivered and by whom and over
what period of time
you want to come back in on that andrew
yeah do you want to take them one at a
time jane if that's okay yeah
yeah yeah if i don't take them one at a
time i'll forget what was asked
go ahead then thank you
and then that is a really point and the
training will be mandatory for every
everybody across the council
and in relation to equalities there will
be certain people who will be doing
like interviews and um you know managing
um groups of staff that will there will
be further training for those
but we hope to get that sort of uh
looked at
in the next couple of months we've
already decided that we're going to make
sure that our
interview panels are always inclusive we
can't we will where possible always have
a woman on the
interview panel we will also look to
have fame staff on the panel
disabled staff etc so we want to touch
all the protected characteristics
and make sure that they are in those um
for recruiting recruiting new staff into
the council i know that's not really
um something that'll happen shortly
because obviously we are in a situation
of cuts unfortunately because the
budgets have been slashed again and but
you know but going forward that those
are the things that we will be looking
at we were making sure that
where possible we will have um all
panels inc
that will be inclusive and we were
trying to use some of that as
development opportunities for staff to
be able to um
you know understand what what the
council actually delivers because i
think that sometimes when you work in a
council you work in an area you just
think that's what the council deliver
i think there's an you know a lack of
understanding for people that work for
the council
and for the residents actually what our
council delivers so i think that
that those are things that we'll be
looking at going forward as well
thank you and that's the next one
the report referred to 0.3.4 with regard
to reducing hate crime
um if this needs to be dealt with at an
early age and education is vital
will contact only be made with head
teachers or will contact be made with
the chairman of governors
so that something like that can be
included on the agenda for governor's
meetings
i'm i'm a governor in school and hate
crime is something that we talk about
anyway so i think as
as governors as councillors as local
authority governors i think that should
be on our agenda
anyway i don't think it needs to be
introduced by the head teacher or
anybody i think that we that's our role
to introduce that
i think it's our role to include
introduce equalities
right across the board it's our role to
talk about the environment in those sort
of meetings so
i would i would be hoping that we
wouldn't have to just
call head teachers to ask them to do
that i would be hoping that
as a group of counselors we will be
taking that into the schools where we
are governors
yeah um 0.4.1 on population and
deprivation
there's actually um a typo in relation
to the west area data
it's on the matrix and it shows the
estimated population in a four-digit
number rather than a five
so just bring that to your attention
um and lastly uh 4.8 looking
at other groups with a known
disadvantage which cares
um the data from the 2011 census that's
a few people recorded as being a carer
by
gp practices um can the ccg
encourage their gp's to get this data
in order for it to be included in the
the jsna
so that you know services that
are maybe hidden to carers you know can
can be
you know can be obtained i think that's
something that we need to take into
um gp practices and i think it became
quite clear during covid
that actually it was really difficult
when we knew that covid was
um was was a potentially
more life-threatening for people from a
vein background we weren't able to
record that
and because gps don't always have that
data so
those are things that the ccg will be
encouraging and
encouraging and gps to record so
obviously alongside
carers and other and others that we
include as
groups that are disadvantaged right
i really you know look forward to this
you know living document evolving
because
you know inequality is something that we
don't want
exactly anyway all right that's why
we've been able thank you very much
thank you
thank you linda thanks um so just to
sum up on this i think i can i think
councillor whitson encapsulated my view
of this which is that it is indicative
of the
sort of organization that we want to be
and i i mean that actually
um for for all councillors i'm sure when
i when i say that and i and i welcome
um council covenant council mr
blackburn's comments there's a really
important
point here that forgive me i may have
missed if councillors later did
make it so my apologies if it has
already been um
said is that you know that when you do
these things it's very easy to pat
yourselves on the back
um but what we have resolved to do is to
ensure that we don't mark our own
homework on this and we will be
enlisting the support of the association
of public service excellent taxi
um to keep a check on this for us i
think that's really important so that we
don't
um become embroiled in our own
little space and celebrate small
achievements when we could be making
larger ones and that we continually
um receive feedback and a benchmark
against what's happening elsewhere so
that we can be as councillors later said
um you know the best in the field when
it comes to equalities both inside the
council
and all over the borough so i'm really
pleased to see this report come forward
the executive
um to consider can they be
approved please
yes sorry i did i did uh forget to say
that we were using um absolutely
and the association of public sector
excellence to actually come and be our
critical friend because
you know what what we've got the
information that we've got currently it
looks like we
you know we are doing really well but
actually we we may just be like you say
marking our homework so i do think it's
a really important
point that we're having a critical
friend to to work alongside us thank you
leader
thanks okay so um that
uh concludes the discussion on that
paper
can the recommendations as per the
report be approved please
thank you okay and then the next item
is the revenue budget monitor for
period eight april to november 2020
councillor ross
please thank you leader so this is
period eight and we're now projecting an
underspend for the year of 2.108 million
which is largely the result of some re
forecasting of
work in we're reforecasting work in
adults and children's services
we have to take that figure with the
usual pinch of salt
obviously these remain very changeable
times any underspender will be added to
the
budget support reserve and will be used
as part of the
future budget planning i have to say
were it not for the fact that we can
spread our
collection deficits in the contacts and
business rates over the next three
financial years
um the f the impact would have been at
8.8 million
um that we'd have to have dealt with
this year
in terms of the covet 19 pressures the
gross pressure is estimated at this
point to be
51.212 million after government support
and other contributions the net impact
is now
4.574 million um you'll also note that
97
of the capital budget for this year is
now committed or programmed to start
so i ask that the executive colleagues
note this report
thanks councillor ross any questions or
comments from members of the
executive no
okay um more widely i've got councillor
myers please
yes thank you thank you leader um
there's no doubt at all that
businesses are having a tough time at
the moment
not just retail businesses but
hospitality so
restaurants and hotels and cafes
are all having a tough time
the reports in section 19 i think of
this year section 19
talks about the possibility of
businesses going bump
and actually being becoming insolvent
and that would
lead to not only the loss of
the non-domestic rate but also the
uh long-term income from from it and
we've had voids and
people being maybe done locally as well
so it'd be quite a tough
tough issue really and on top of that
um the government have been supporting
the these uh these businesses
through the rate uh relief and we have
to actually repay
some of the money back to government as
well as that were to happen
can i ask has a uh has the council done
any modeling
to see if there were more cases like uh
like
debenhams going bump uh and what the
lightning
impact would be thank you leader
that's the ross thank you i'm not aware
i was doing any
economic modelling in that respect for
for covid
uh i can only i will pass on to um to to
graham and or nikki shortly but i i
can only agree that we are we've
obviously
we're already in a recession we're
looking at a double dip because of the
um
ongoing situation with the necessary
health restrictions
and obviously as a result of that um
even with the
government support in terms of the
grants and the business rates relief
that have been paid
it may well be that some businesses will
not be able to survive this
uh this very very challenging um
challenging situation so in that respect
then we would look at losing the
potential revenue we would have had from
business rates you'd be looking at
people being unfortunately made
unemployed which
obviously has an impact on council tax
collections and
payment of council tax support so the
situation isn't great
i know from a brexit perspective we are
looking at the impact of what's happened
over the the new
year in terms of the covered one though
i'm just going to check in with uh nikki
or graham to see if
if there is anything there that we can
do because i think that's a very good
point councilor myers
i think just
just to add to that um thanks
councillor ross and first council of
mines for your question i think
we have been monitoring closely business
rates throughout the year
for that simple reason that we have
quoted the number in the report which is
just in excess of 90 million pounds of
rate relief that's been granted to our
retail businesses
during the course of the year and we are
mindful that
there'll be a final reconciliation of
that at the end of march so
basically if retail premises have closed
the government will come back and say
well we gave you the retail relief on
the basis they're open
and they'll be a reconciliation and
potentially repayment back
i think it's it's fair to say at this
stage and through the monitoring we've
done
that there are not not a significant not
material difference
the for the grant that we have been
given
but that's not to say next financial
year
we won't be in a more difficult position
and i think that
depends to some extent on what the
government announced in the
budget i think we expect in march where
there should be further announcements as
to
what continuing support government may
be given to the retail businesses
so at this stage at this stage we're not
anticipating any material issues in
respect of 2021
thanks graeme um councillor cockins
thank you briefly just to mostly thank
the finance staff and
any of the executive members involved in
this because uh like most of you
i've followed our budget trajectory
throughout this year with
increasing horror and 51 million impact
of a total of 175 is
is absolutely enormous and um i suppose
there's some relief that that
it's coming together to some extent now
was very much aware that the next few
years we will be
paying the price for this so really just
stamped to say
to say thank you to those who've had to
um to be on the front line of the
financial crisis
thanks um councillor cobbins that's
appreciated
um i'm not seeing anybody else wanting
to come
in on this so um the reports for noting
but also to note the
um movement in the earmarked reserves
also so can those two
recommendations be approved please
thank you um the next item is an update
on the
boundary review for trafford and
um this is obviously an a political
report so it is to
be um moved by the chief exec sarah todd
thank you leader um members will be
aware that trafford is required to
um to undertake a boundary review by the
local government boundary commission
and some of you will have been around
the last time this happened which is
uh the best part of 18 years ago now so
some very very significant changes in
trafford
over that last two decades including the
fact that we have seen
uh 11 population increase up to now
so um timely that we do this review
um the report is updating i'm not going
to go through it in detail
but suffice just to draw out a couple of
key points
the first of which is that the review
timetable has
has changed it's been reviewed itself
and revised as a consequence of the
challenges and pressures and demands
that the pandemic has placed upon us
and very much acknowledged by the local
government boundary commission
so it is a two-stage process and it
culminates in
uh all-out council elections in 2023
now and we are working to a cross party
member working group throughout this uh
entire process
and so the report does update on the
first stage
which is um the
determining the future size of the
council in relation to the numbers of
councillors
and awards we are due to submit this
by the second of february so next week
but as we've said in the report the
broad conclusions
are that there is a very good basis for
us maintaining
the existing size so 63 councillors
across
21 wards should the boundary commission
accept this
and it will have a chunk of evidence
that sits
alongside of it some highlights of which
are drawn out in the report
will then move to stage two which is
the work that will enable us to de-mark
the future
ward boundaries and that work will
continue
for the coming months with the
submission date of the 24th
of august just to say finally this
report is here for information
uh only because we wanted to make sure
it was
uh in the public domain and you have had
sight of it i
dropped you a note last week um but the
responsibility for the submission does
rest with myself as chief exec so
i shall leave it there thank you
thank you sarah are there any questions
or comments from members of the
executive
no any questions or comments more widely
councillor morgan
please thank you leader
um uh can i begin by thanking um
the chief executive and all of the
officers for i know the um
a huge amount of work that's gone on
particularly by dan and adrian
um on this um i know it's um
a lot of work to um to even begin the
start of this process
can i um um the in the working group um
it was mentioned that
we should we'll have a site of the
submission before the deadline of next
tuesday
and just wondering if um chief executive
could get updated
on that oversight thank you
thanks sarah are you able to do that yes
that should be just fine i if i tell you
that i haven't seen the the final
submission just yet we are still um
dotting eyes and crossing tees but yeah
we will share that with the working
group
thank you thank you that's great okay
um so the report is just for um noting
keen to get it into the public domain
can that be noted please
thank you okay um the next item is
urgent business of which there is
none followed by the exclusion
resolution
um i will read it because we are online
just to say for anybody watching um
that this is um to consider some
confidential
um or commercially sensitive matters and
the um the motion reads
that the public be excluded from this
meeting during consideration of the
remaining items on the agenda
because of the likelihood of disclosure
of exempt information which falls within
one
or more descriptive category or
categories of the local government act
1972 schedule 12
a as amended by the local government
access to information variation order
2006
and specified on the agenda item or
report relating to each
such item respectively and can
is that approved by the executive i
all right you okay could we um end the
recording
there then please joe yes leader i'll
just do that and let you know
immediately when we're okay to go ahead
thanks